deswegen fragt ihr euch jetzt bestimmt
wie sie ist ja so einer kleinen einsamen
insel als recht unspektakulär
hallo meine lieben freuen und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge der
minecraft commands ihr habt euch
gewünscht ich hab zwar morgen boni und
ist es gerade zwei uhr aber ihr habt
euch gewünscht und den wunsch möchte ich
euch natürlich nicht wegnehmen wie kann
man wie gaal ich muss wirklich sagen
dass bisher von den drei folgen die ich
bisher von dieser neuen serie gemacht
habe ist das wirklich muss ich sagen
finde ich bisher die coolsten kommentare
die ich je bekommen habe also ich könnte
echt wirklich jede sache so einfach
abknutschen den wunsch und coole sachen
zugesendet ich hoffe ihr empfindet das
dann am ende auch so ich würde mich
überhaupt freuen wenn ihr bis zum ende
dran wäre ich am ende noch mal eine
sache ansprechen möchte die mir selber
so ein bisschen auf dem herzen liegt
deswegen fangen wir aber erstmal an mit
command 0 euro an
erst mal freunde bevor mich wieder so
viele fragen mich fragen ich nie jemand
aber ich gebe euch trotzdem immer der
cee'd ich bin hier und irgendwo gespart
und wir haben hier so ich weiß ja bis
hält aber jetzt hat ja was ein
krankenwagen direkt vor der tür her bin
nach vorne irgendwo gespannt hier ist
alles voll mit diesem coolen savanne
bäumen da sonne kleine insel übergang
dingsbums hier sind sowohl berge und
alles mögliche hinten in dem in dem
nebel fassung jesu kleine inselchen da
so kleine inselchen finde ich ganz cool
aber der erste command wurde mir
zugesendet von duplo duplo mitte
geschrieben er meint das ist ein slime
kreisel und der command ist der hier der
ist zu lang hierfür deswegen habe ich
mir natürlich wieder ein command blog
geholt hier einen lepper darauf gibt den
command hier ein und ich klicke auf dann
und ihr seht schon das ist ein riesiger
slum kreisel der umher hüpft und ich
habe versucht vorhin schon sein zu
formen und zu töten
allerdings ist es leider so wenn man
einen tötet wenn ich den hier
beispielsweise tötete
seht ihr schon der zerfällt jeden moment
in seine anderen slams
das heißt ich habe auf jeden fall ein
problem dieses ding jetzt aus der welt
zu schaffen
und naja das korrigieren vollkommen
nummer eins ist wieder mit dieser riding
heidi zusammen mit verbunden also einen
kleinen größe gehe und die eine bereitet
einen kleinen größe die und die idee
rheins leyen will ver di und die reitet
und mir sind hier eindeutig viel zu
viele slums der viel zu kleinen größe
deswegen würde ich sagen wir gehen
schnell weiter zum fag nummer zwei in
einer anderen location und das machen
wir es oft nicht mehr kratz ohne ich
stand ja vorhin da hinten auf diesem
berg drauf und hab euch den ersten fleck
dort vorgestellt aber ich dachte diese
berge gezeigt und so wenn ich hierhin ge
ist eine riesige wüste alte also das ist
auch so gar keinen sinn fom habe ich den
sieg gar nicht eingeplant jedenfalls ist
das derzeit den wieder eingeblendet wird
aber wir kommen auch jetzt schon zu
command nummer zwei damit zu gesendet
wurde von mainboard und zwar schreibt er
das ist ein krieg patrol zumindest hab
ich den sogenannten zwar hat er mir
diesen command zugesendet schrägstrich
ntt data et also etwa heißt gar nicht
alle lte heißt entity betrieb leitet
doppelpunkt 1 das problem ist jetzt dass
ich hier gerade keinen creeper see und
zwar erstmal was macht dieser command
warum nämlich den krieg patrol der
command heißt einfach die patrol weil er
ob man hier sogar zweiter weil er alle
creeper in der umgebung bzw
man kann da auch ein radius noch dazu
ein geben ich mache jetzt erstmal alle
creeper in dieser welt werden damit
explodiert also wenn ihr mann auf diese
krippe hier achtet ich zünde ja nicht an
die sind nicht aggressiv auf mich oder
so aber kommt mir einmal nicht so nahe
du so ich habe hier den command ich
drücke enter und ihr seht schon und die
explodieren einfach ich weiß nicht ob
ich irgendwo anders auch prima
explodiert sind da unten sieht so aus
als ob einer explodiert wäre
dass das sieht nicht nach riva loch aus
der story noch drüber loch aus das sieht
nach kripo noch aus das diner wand keine
ahnung ob das ein kripperl loch ist das
hier unten weiß ich auch nicht ob das
triberger sind keine ahnung ob das alles
prima löcher sind das da sieht nach wie
vor noch aus aber ich kann auf jeden
fall damit alle käufer die sich derzeit
in meiner welt befinden einfach mal in
die luft sprengen vielleicht sehen wir
noch irgendwie okay ich habe auf jeden
fall da war eine kleine explosion gerade
noch die spanier immer neue und auch die
in den höhlen sind allem explodieren und
ich fände
warum ich diesen command tree patrol
genannt habe
wenn ihr beispielsweise beinahe zb bei
der
epic patch mister trump mit komme im
waren extrem viele krippen einer
situation dann hätte ich rein
theoretisch diesen command eingekriegt
eingeben können und ein creeper wäre
gewesen wenn wir einfach tot gewesen und
ich auch weil er ganz viele creeper
waren aber ich glaube ihr wisst dass
meine auf einem online server mit einem
kumpel oder so wer das glaube ich schon
mega fresh wenn man mit so einem command
einfach alles explodieren lassen könnte
was gerade in der umgebung rumläuft und
das war kummer nummer zwei und jetzt
kommt's command nummer roman numero drei
wurde mir zugesendet von mars er heißt
wirklich magst ich habe den namen noch
nie gehört ich finde den namen aber
eigentlich ganz frisch und zwar habe ich
diesen command einfach rüstungs ständer
mensch genannt jetzt fragt euch was ist
ein rüstungs ständer mensch und zwar der
command ist erst mal zusammen also wir
spawnen einen arm ostend wieso steht
dass hannah montana moslem weil es ein
entity ist das habe ich mittlerweile
gelernt wähle wähle wähle das heißt auf
unserer jetzigen situation sei jetzigen
position scheint also dass die arme
gezeigt werden soll jetzt zeigen wir uns
das ganze dilemma an
wir sehen hier ist eine rüstung ständer
und der hat arme normalerweise mal eben
hier zur info wenn ich hier einfach dass
ein gebe ohne charme seht ihr das ist
normalerweise ein rüstung ständer an den
hier kann ich nicht irgendwie das dran
packenden kopf könnte ich da rein
theoretisch kompakt aber den hier kann
ich noch ein schwert rand acken
beispielsweise im kopf das heißt dass
hier den ich einfach sowohl rüstung
ständer mensch weil er einfach viel mehr
wie so ein mensch aussieht der rechte
die so ein bisschen natürlich wenn dein
kopf als die daumen bisschen aus wie
mensch aber dadurch das rating aber hat
finde ich extrem cool was mich jetzt
allerdings mal wundern würde wenn das
doch hier so ein ding ist kann ich nicht
hier weil es ja auch ein entity ist
einfach mal mein katars eingeben unable
to sammelobjekt wahrscheinlich habe ich
mich bei einer ganz anderen sache
verschrieben und ich erzähle wieder ein
bullshit und alle beleidigen mich in den
kommentaren der sich zum ende bin ich
aber na ja das finde ich auf jeden fall
recht cool und deswegen habe ich rüstung
ständer mensch genannt weil das teil
einfach zu verscherzen hat manu der
vierte roman meine lieben freunde wurde
mir zugesendet wieso sage ich eigentlich
immer meine lieben freunde ich meine
sind ja auch freundinnen quasi ich
bräuchte damals ein wort mit dem ich
euch alle zusammen fast jeder hat ja
irgendwie solche wörter irgendwer hat
zwölf york ist ungeheuer
alles mögliche gibt und ich sage immer
freunde
das ist zwar schön dass wir befreundet
sind dabei irgendwie es ist doch recht
langweilig ihr seid ihr wegen den
community und nicht wegen meinem video
also ich habe hier diesen command
zugesendet willkommen
von dem lieben scotty und zwar nennt er
ihn feuer breitete sich dann in
feuerball punkt einfach nur feuerball
punkt das ist dieser roman bei mir sein
manchmal so komische zeichen weil der
langsam enter gedrückt wurde und das
kann dass google doch nicht richtig
verarbeiten jedenfalls kann ich einfach
mal enter drücken und ihr seht schon oh
gott oh gott oh gott wie die bedingen
das ist zum glück noch nicht auf den
boden geknallt und zwar ist das ein
feuerball und wir können da mal selbst
gegen schlagen deswegen fragt ihr euch
jetzt bestimmt diese ist ja so einer
kleinen einsamen insel als recht
unspektakulär schneider jetzt diesen
feuerball würde ich mal sagen einfach
mal zu der wüste hin
das ist uns natürlich zu wenig wissen
davon noch ein paar mehr und ich geb dir
die explodiert schon versetzt ihr seht
damit kann man quasi so feuerbälle
machen die nicht nur einen kleinen
umkreis von ihm voll machen mit dem
feuer sondern so ein paar mehr
ich zeige euch dass man hier noch mal
wenn wir mal so ein paar mehr davon
wollen machen das wollte er jetzt ist
sie auf jeden fall schon so ein bisschen
mehr in die luft geflogen ist ist
natürlich kein tnt was alles in die luft
reißt sondern es macht mir diese lücken
und verbrennt da so ein bisschen was
also schon recht frisch vor allem wenn
ihr das einfach in einem wald macht
können damit einfach den ganzen wald
abfackeln das war auf jeden fall war
das ist schon ein bisschen viel
angerichtet dafür dass ich jetzt nur 56
stückes pont ab vor allem hier ist
einfach mal noch das war oder sind sogar
noch mehr diesen teilweise nicht mehr
alle drauf geflogen also ich hab noch
weniger gespannt
guck da habe ich einen drauf und dann
ist er wieder sein ganzes stück weg also
die machen doch schon ganz schön viel
schaden muss ich zugeben
das war auf jeden das ja auch noch
welche kommen diesen gar nicht alle da
drauf geflogen hier alle halo kommt ein
einsatz noch eben runter segeln und ihr
seht schon
also das war auf jeden fall kommen
markiert er bot mir zugesendet von
scotty er heißt einfach nur feuerball
und ihr seht schon was einfach so ein
feuerball anrichten kann
freunde bei diesem fünften command muss
ich wirklich sagen es tut mir sorry aber
hier ist tut mir sorry es tut mir leid
aber hier stand eigentlich mal ein
creeper aber der naja ich sags mal so
ihr müsst euch vorstellen kleinen luca
geht in das google docs formular guckt
sich so an hey there delilah
zugeschrieben guck mir das ansehen 7487
comments command die mir zu gesendet
wurden bei den effekt sitzt schon
fünfstellig jedenfalls lag wie das ok
ich suche mal ein paar command ausbaut
ich schon mal auf teste die und so
weiter
und den habe ich schon mal aufgebaut
weil der recht lange gedauert hat die
wollte ich nicht in der folge aufbauen
sondern den forschen aufgebaut und dann
habe ich das ist eigentlich ein command
wo ich hier bin so formuliert hier so
zusammengerückt hier ist ein schwert und
hier stand ein krieg und wisst ihr warum
der kripo da nicht mehr stehen können ja
noch an den zweiten command erinnern
alle creeper in dieser welt werden damit
explodiert
genau das ist der grund warum der krieg
nicht mehr steht
wahrscheinlich habe ich eine luft
gesprengt oder es war halt einfach
seinen keeper der keine explosion
gemacht das heißt wenn ihr euch fragten
wieso ist denn hier kein loch das ist
ein krieger der ist hat keine also der
ist einfach nur hier gespannt worden
hier müsst ihr euch quasi vorstellen
steht einfach so einen krieg und hat
schon schwert in sich ihr seht
wahrscheinlich auch auf dem terminal
beziehungsweise ich jetzt einfach mal
ein so sieht das ganze dann nämlich
eigentlich aus und nun ja wir kommen
jetzt mal wieder zurück zum eigentlichen
bild und zwar hab ich ja was vollkommen
blocking gesetzt ab dann kommt ein
gegeben dass das schwert gespannt wer
dann habe ich ihnen kommen blocking
gesetzt dass ich da gesprochen werde
und das ist alex extrem lang und extrem
kompliziert gewesen aber es kommt von
jan carganico lp und es ist richtig
richtig cool so zusammenfassung falls
jetzt quasi noch nicht wisst was den wir
hier gemacht hat er hat mir quasi
einfach drei commands geschickt ich
sollte genau hier einen kommentar
hinsetzen hier ankommen block und da in
den boden ein
und dann wird durch den in den boden
wurde hier einfach ein schwert gespannt
durch den runter wurden krieges born und
hier wird einfach ich als samen
hergestellt mit der rüstungen schwert
zum glück kein helm auf weil damit meine
die masse sieht und so ihr habt ja schon
das bild zum einblenden gesehen wo ich
vor ein foto von gemacht habe einfach
damit ihr seht das ist auf jeden fall
richtig frisch aus und das muss ich
sagen wir bisher so der cool zu kommen
damit zugesandt wurde war einfach seine
eigene kampfsituation minecraft die sich
nicht mehr bewegt sondern einfach so
bleibt ich schon ganz frisch sieht schon
ganz cool aus und das war command nummer
fünf jahre meine lieben freunde und
damit würde ich auch schon sagen war es
das für diese command wie süß kann die
tintenfische schwimmen so beck wenn ich
da so hin schwebe schon frech ich würde
schon sagen das ist das für diese dritte
commands folge war und jetzt komme ich
mal zu der sache die ich am anfang
gesagt habe bitte wenn ihr jetzt keine
lust habe darauf dass ich jetzt noch
eine minute kurz emmental werde und um
schreie dann könnte auf jeden fall schon
mal abschalten dann bedanke mich fürs
zuschauen an alle anderen wenn jetzt
noch dran seid ich lieb euch viel mehr
als jeder abgeschaltet haben ein schwarz
und zwar geht es mir um eine kleine
sache die ihm unter dem letzten
videopreis aufgefallen ist der kamen
setzte video war wo ich das buch
vorgestellt habe und ein andere youtuber
hat dieses buch wird auch schon mal
vorgestellt
ich bin den ganzen tag von 8 bis 16 uhr
in der uni habe danach noch training
sport irgendwie was anderes und dann
komme ich nach hause und nach noch ein
video und dann setze ich mich an seinem
video 1 2 stunden und ich las hoch und
das meiste was ich und dem video sehe
ist hate weil mir gesagt wird du hast es
geklaut und ich denke buch her
woher das ist ein gott verdammter
command wenn ich game mode 1 1 gb oder
times sagte dann auch ich hätt's geklaut
vor allem von einem youtuber der da der
den kommandant quasi auch geklaut hat
dieser begriff geklaut ist aber auch
komplett falsch weil er die nicht
geklaut sondern den hat ein amerikaner
veröffentlicht auf seiner facebook-seite
und diese pace pin seite wurde mir
geschickt wollte wissen dass andere den
schon gezeigt haben und wieso ist es
dann von mir geklaut aber von anderen
nicht also ich verstehe das nicht
ich wollte das war es auch eigentlich
schon ich wollte euch einfach nur sagen
freunde
ihr müsst euch vorstellen ich krieg da
kommentare und da habe ich sogar diese
bestätigung extra drin dass man sagen
soll ich habe ihn kopiert oder ich hab
ihn nicht kopiert und ich habe dem thema
bekommen da steht stand immer nein ich
habe ihn nicht kopiert und da dachte ich
einfach den hut irgendwann amerikaner
einfach bei minecraft geposteten der
wird jetzt bei twitter veröffentlicht
oder so und die ich gucke dann einfach
und wollte ihnen zeigen und das einzige
was kommt es ja in den boutiquen dann
freut euch doch das eben schon kannte
das ist doch einfach nur dass sie dann
informiert darüber als ich verstehe
nicht wieso dann mir irgendwas gesagt
wird und ich wieder als [ __ ]
dargestellt werde was gegen meine mutter
geht also ich verstehe nicht was sowas
soll meistens selbst dann irgendwelche
kleinen kinder die dann meinen das ist
cool wenn wir den beleidigen also ich
find's ganz cool wenn ihr sowas sieht
einfach dass sie mit solchen leuten
nicht so umgeht und zurück beleidigt
sondern einfach sagt du bist ein
schlechter mensch das ist traurig was du
machst so was einfach weil ich finde es
traurig wenn man deswegen leute
beleidigt aber das war auf jeden fall so
eine sache die mich noch gestört hat die
ich jetzt noch kurz zum ende hier
bringen wollte und das habe ich jetzt
getan ich werde übrigens demnächst auch
so ein video machen wo ich einfach mal
so ein paar sachen sagen möchte dir die
ich mir ein die sich angestaut haben
über die zeit nicht sonne es soll jetzt
nicht so ein video werden wo ich mit
allen alle fertig machen oder so sondern
einfach wo ich ein bisschen über mich
selber reden und was mich stört und so
also ein ganz friedliches video nicht
dass ihr jetzt denkt so weil es hier los
mit dem oder irgendwie wird ich würde
auf jeden fall erstmal sagen das was mit
dem video wirklich mega bei den
bewertungen freuen
und wenn ihr commands habt und in der
beschreibung ist das commands formular
da könnt ihr einfach euren kommt rein
schreiben müsst ihr euch nicht für
anmelden oder so es ist gerade wie
gesagt irgendwie mitten in der nacht ich
habe morgen und nicht vier stunden
schlaf
ich muss das erst mal anders planen rote
augen ich habe
augenringe ich weiß ich dass alles
länger unter einen hut kriegt mit
youtube und schule eventuell höre ich
dann auch mit youtube aber mal schauen
wir da erst mal
wir sehen uns in einem anderen video
wieder